yeah my name is Josh wise Bach and this
morning I'm speaking on high fidelity
web crawling and Python if you need to
contact me or one contact me after you
can find me on Twitter at Josh wise Bach
where I'm always talking hockey
sometimes Python and a lot of running my
emails also on my bio there so I want to
thank Pi data so let me speak this
morning I'm feeling a bit a little bit
impostor syndrome here because they
spent all yesterday listening to a lot
of awesome talk and I feel a lot of
people are doing really awesome price
applications and procuring off a lot of
awesome presentations everything's way
above what I'm doing at least what I'm
feeling today I'm seeing a little bit
more on the technical side I am wanting
to share with you guys my lessons that
I've learned from taking python scripts
and turn something that that are more
robust that you can trust and run
routinely so what that means is Python
makes it really easy for you to scrape
the internet but those simple scripts
aren't something I would trust to run on
routine chrome job on a server to
collect thousands of webpages on a
routine basis and this is just something
I've learned from my experience to my
work and what I'm going to share today
so just a brief outline I'm going to
talk to you briefly on Python web
scraping should be pretty familiar I'll
talk some of the issues that come with
it and then I'll just get into the basic
lessons I've learned
they can be described at a high level as
logging dynamically on dynamic web pages
so dealing with JavaScript and
navigating barriers when websites just
don't want you to be scraping them so
give a little background myself so you
know where I'm coming from my name is
Josh Weiss block by day I work for the
Canadian federal government in the
Department of National Defense in
Victoria BC where I'm a communications
manager at night time I moonlight in the
National Hockey League
I do data analytics so basically
Moneyball work with the Florida Panthers
specifically on their amateur scouting
team so our job is to try and find 17 18
year old kids who will someday hopefully
play in the NHL so we can draft them and
have exclusive rights to deal with
contracts with them I started getting to
Python and hockey way back in 2006 2010
without studying computer science up in
a Simon Fraser University in Vancouver
that's where I really got to choose
Python the basic concepts of Python and
the basics I use today
salsa where he started to really get to
hockey from 2012-2014 I moved out east
to Ottawa Ontario where did my Master's
computer science University of Ottawa
and I study machine learning natural
language processing and I was actually
doing my thesis based on hockey
analytics and part of my thesis work
required collecting data every day so I
could actually perform my experiments
and complete my thesis and graduate part
of that was using Python where I had
scripts running every day to collect
routine data and that's where I really
started to learn some of these lessons
and run it on these issues and the that
ultimately end up getting hired by the
National Hockey League in 2015 that with
some public research I had on the hockey
blogosphere and as part of the team one
of our main responsibilities is handling
the entire data pipeline for our team so
I'm the main person responsible for the
collection of data for the validation
verification data for the storage and
presentation visualization and when I
have some time I work with the other
analysts to actually convert our stats
into costume language so that the
traditional Scouts can understand have
caught a conversation same language
so if you've ever done any type of data
science course online you'll find a very
first thing that they always do is to
give you a very nice data set the IRS
one is very common example so rate way
you have this great data set you start
analyzing you start working on it you
start asking questions with it but
that's not the reality within the real
world you end up finding 80% your work
is just getting the data and getting
into usable state there's a great talk
yesterday on rolling and the presenter
ends up expired explain this greatly
motives work was just trying to get the
data into a usable format from scraping
who's having issues within the same
thing ideals in hockey where you can't
trust data you're getting you'll find a
example such as players birthdays are
wrong Heights are wrong you'll never
find a 5 foot 11 hockey player on the
internet and then once you actually get
your data you need to actually analyze
and that's that's the final step but
most of work is actually getting it so
really my talk here again is focusing on
the very first step again your data not
the collecting so this is a very simple
example of how to scrape a Python if
you've done any type of work like this
before it's pretty familiar there's a
lot of great built-in modules with
Python request URL Lib and simply feed
it a URL that URL can have daily reports
that could be update daily in that you
want collect information from you
passage the requests module and then you
passage your parsing function the
parsing function can do whatever you
wanted to common example would be to use
some like beautiful soup and hopefully
not reg X to parse the HTML finally the
information that you need store it and
then return the function was successful
it's really in this talk I care about
lines 5 and 7 I don't care what the
function is doing I just care about
getting the HTML to the function and
that the function worked that's really
where we're going to focus a
so that script is great it's great if
you want to run it on your terminal you
write it quickly code it up execute it
grab some data you're good to go that's
not a script I would trust to run on a
server every day at 2:00 a.m. to grab
data from a bunch of different websites
especially when Knox is grabbing one
page you're grabbing hundreds of
thousands the internet by its nature is
ugly it's held together duct-tape things
don't work the way they should sometimes
most of the time you have network
connectivity issues servers might be
down your internet connection might do
them there's a number of issues that can
actually cause you to fail your script
to fail and that's where these lessons
really came into play
so scripts can fail for a number of
reasons in Python this is probably the
easiest and simplest lesson but it's
probably most important websites can
change I'll send you the website you're
scraping has a new layout your parsing
function fails and you don't and you
have to able clock date anymore maybe
their server doesn't work maybe your
internet connection doesn't work you
need to be aware of these failures on
your scripts before before your users
spot it there's nothing more
embarrassing as a Data Manager then when
your users coming to you telling you
that your data is out of date so the
very solution this you need to be
alerted Python makes it easy in a number
of ways for you to know when your script
fails you can you email yourself with
something built in such as SMTP Lib or
you can use a text or SMS with Tullio
importantly you need to know what went
wrong a lot of great again use built-in
features such as blogging module to
capture all kinds of relative data are
important data you need to know what
website fails when they failed any input
parameters you need to know what part
your script failed so you can try and
debug what went wrong and importantly
you also need to know what went wrong on
the website too they give you 200 error
a 403 error a 404 or 500 error seeing
time to figure out whether it was the
service problem where the server blocked
you or whether something went wrong on
the server
so that was a that one's very quick very
easy but some important some that kind
of built into the next three lessons
really and looking next forward is a
dynamic website traditionally our
internet was built on static HTML those
are super easy to scrape and Python but
now we have a large rise within
JavaScript frameworks react angular
ember cetera all these load up as an
HTML page the JavaScript then
dynamically generates your content and
loads it into the web page this makes it
really difficult for Python a scrape on
its own using requestors or URL Lib what
using the browser won't be necessarily
what Python sees and sometimes reverse
engineering these JavaScript API isn't
the most resource friendly like side of
your script if your reverse engineering
100,000 pages you probably don't have
the manpower to do that so the solution
that is selenium while you probably
selenium for testing but it can also you
use for generating for web scraping
websites you can combine it with phantom
jf and now you have a headless browser
you can actually use to dynamically
generate the job or execute the
JavaScript so you can actually load the
content on the pages you're trying to
scrape Sanjay s is actually shutting
down right now the author has given up
on the project due to the rise of
chromium so that's going to start
shifting toward chromium rather than
fancy-ass but there are a lot of
different alternatives such as Firefox
XV FB scrapie and Splinter
so what that looks like in Python is
just quickly they're swapping out your
request module with selenium I use the
pen to Jeff's web browser or browsers
what I would use again you feed it URL
on the same method now your browser can
grab the HTML any pass the function but
you're still doing run into problems
with this again poor network
connectivity poor servers or poorly
designed websites and all the other
issues that come up with the Internet
can hinder loading of the JavaScript
timeout issues are common one where just
takes too long and selenium gives up and
grabs what it has which is an incomplete
webpage which means you won't have all
your content which will cause your
you're parsing function to fail there
are a couple ways we can actually
address this three solutions that kind
of came up with starting with the
ugliest which is simply use the time
method I'm shaking see the problem with
that we look at that insect basically do
is you're looking up web pages you and
you tell your script wait a certain
amount of time for the JavaScript to
load and then you grab the content
this is a very crude method because you
don't know exactly how long is going to
take that the website to load the
JavaScript content you can be waiting
too long so now you're wasting resources
and processing times let's say so if
you're doing 100,000 web or pages your
scripting function go from two hours to
72 hours and vice versa I can get the
opposite where you're not waiting long
enough
and you're running the same situation
where you're still not loading the
content so there's an inclusion that is
selenium has a great expected conditions
built in function it basically tells the
browser to not move forward until a
certain condition is met so basically
when a certain element is loaded the
common one and I love to use CSS
selectors within HTML tags and I know
should be on the page and you also give
it a certain amount of time to sleep for
so it will wait 15 seconds as an example
until the CSS element load 'add since
loaded will contain forward if it hits
15 seconds will give up and forward and
that's the issue
so that was improving all the time but
it can still fail if the website is
poorly designed which happens in real
world you're still gonna fail at
grabbing the content we also require no
CSS Lecter's whatever other elements you
want to select for the web page so kind
of the solution I came up with that it's
not pretty but it's effective basically
you're trying until you're past your
going to throw that same code into an
infinite loop and you're going to keep
trying until it gets a webpage you want
to have some sort of check so you're not
spinning forever because there could be
legitimate reasons why it can't load
such as the website no longer exists or
the server may be down so you want to do
some sort of what I would do is give it
a max attempt so basically you're saying
you're going to keep trying this to
request this web page pass it to the
parsing function if it fails we'll try
again and if it fails 10
times then we're going to log that error
you're going to learn yourself as the
data manager that something went wrong
log it and move on this actually works
pretty effectively in some of the use
cases that I have came across it with so
it's ugly but it's simple it does work
easy to implement you can combine it
with the expected condition so your
waiting the optimal time hopefully I've
even added a time delay between rupes
just to give it some so you're not
hammering the website with requests and
again logging and alerting is required
the first lesson that we learned you
need to know when when something broke
and why it was broken
so it kind of leads into the third
lesson websites might not want you and
if you keep hammering into requests
you're going to DDoS them so you kind of
need to throttle your own scripts
websites might not want you for a number
reason so it's kind of an ethical
question whether you should be scraping
them and that's up to the individual
person you need should be respecting
your neighbors on the Internet
I shouldn't be hampering their resources
and you should be respecting robots.txt
ideally websites would have some sort of
API gets great from but again it's not
always the case but sometimes the data
manager you need your data for whatever
your your your project is so you need to
find these solutions that prevent your
your callers from detecting that you are
crawling them and blocking your IP
very simple solution create a proxy
server for those who don't know a proxy
server is basically a man-in-the-middle
you're feeding your cluster your
computer goes to a secondary computer
who requests the resource goes back to
the middleman and it goes back to you
this can be done really easily
quite simply spinning up a VPS or any
you can use all you prefer just lotion
legging is winnowed Amazon Google the
old computer you have in your closet you
just need another computer to act as a
middleman when you're using a lot of
these VPS services you can actually use
their API so you can actually continue
to make this autonomous so you don't
need to be creating a VPS by hand every
week when you're running the script or
every night when you're running the
script and creating a proxy server is
really technically or technically it's
easy to do that SSH command you just
identify which port you want to be
feeding your request through and it's
and you have a proxy server and one line
now you can Ford your request through
this proxy that you've just created you
can test it from any other terminal just
send a curl request through your socket
v connection to the IP that you know
from your VPS through the port that
you've created and you should be able to
request a website this works you can now
feed this into your Python script or
have a man the middle requests your
resources for you but the trick here is
you don't want to use just one proxy so
example what I would be doing real life
I would create anywhere between two and
five normally three proxies I create
them as a list I know their IPS I know
the ports and again on every request all
you do is you pick a random proxy and
you feed it into your into the key
arguments within the request module and
plenty and can do something that can do
this similarly and now you're requesting
or rather than your servers requesting
any the resource you have amount and
it'll requesting for you and by randomly
doing this
you're constantly hopping so the
requesting server will not be able to
easily detect
one person is crawling them but it
doesn't end just there you have to
change your headers and your user agent
so you appears that different physical
devices or different browsers are
requesting the resource from the
requesting server yeah see they're
careful here because different websites
react differently to the user that's
requests Sam so you'll notice that when
a mobile device loads up web page versus
your computer device you may get
different contents to kind of experiment
with that so the default is the bottom
line there I'm not gonna read it out but
that is important because if the
requesting server has any type of
detection or crawling detection and it
notices the same the same header
repeatedly requesting resources from
their machine over and over and over
even from different IPS it may trigger
that of their crawl they're bought
detection so to try and eliminate that
issue what I do is I have a text file
about 900 different legitimate headers
and you can find these on Google there's
the quick search and really same thing
as the proxies you feed the you load up
the list and every choice along with
selecting a random proxy you select a
random user header and same thing the
proxy is seeing is a keyword argument to
request you also beat the headers so now
it looks like different devices on
different machines are requesting the
server and that just leads into another
issue also in your slamming the device
and again you got to you got to slow
down these requests so you are ddossing
them again being a good neighbor and
also it's easily triggering to about
detection if the server notices the same
three IPS even with different addresses
they were hammering them at the request
very quickly that doesn't look like a
normal users requesting so you need to
put some sort of time timer in between
requests a simple solution being just a
random sleep between every request
between 1 5 seconds and all of these
combined will hopefully look make it
look like an actual users or look
loading of webpages versus a script
again you still need to log this in case
your your scripts break you need to know
is all sending them on your IP is banned
and you need to know what went wrong so
combining all three it makes it really
easy to hide yourself as a bot or a
scraper crawling looking for resources
improves the chances exceeding but the
problem is now it's going to be really
slow again I use the real elect example
is I have a script where every week I
need to scrape out 100,000 pages and I
found myself going from two hours to 72
hours so but if on the other hand if you
don't do that you're going to be banned
and you can't crawl the resource so it's
kind of its internal discussion that
they have of how important it is to
scrape and what you need to scrape when
you do this great
so just to wrap up the three lessons
learned like when your traditional
scripts in Python are really easy to
grab breezers from the website but to
put into production onto a routine on to
server that routinely requests from
resources whether it's one page or
100,000 pages and there's every whether
it's daily weekly monthly you have to
put some redundancies in there too to
make sure the scripting keep going first
one being logging you need to be aware
it's something breaks so you can address
it right away and need to know how it
broke so you can actually debug what
went wrong
the rise of JavaScript is made things
more difficult with it in Python
scraping so you need to be able handle a
JavaScript loaded that created content
and you do that easily through the use
of headless browsers but you still need
to address the issue that arise from
poor websites so you need to put
redundancies to keep trying even when
the internet doesn't want you to and the
final one is just bought bought
prevention how to get your scripts
around crawling on the Internet
so for website how to get around botched
action so basically the use of proxies
that you want to route random eight
random randomly generates through
through the use of user headers so you
can look like different devices are
requesting and throttling it so it looks
like it's more naturally humans are
naturally requesting it so the none of
these are really elegant or beautiful
but like so they're very simple and
they're effective and I found in my
years of using them it greatly allows me
to trust that the scripts on creating
are going to grab the data that I need
every day so I'll turn over for
questions
earthquakes
[Applause]
so what sort of a very scraping from so
I'll give an example
yeah hockey data player data within the
Panthers we like said we're doing with
amateur scouting soredemo players across
the globe who are 1718 there's thousands
and thousands of leagues and within the
league's are thousands of players so
it's constantly getting up-to-date
information on players across leagues so
we can have a breadth of knowledge of
who's elder Andrew succeeding are those
you are easiest one is in my case I use
one website that has a whole bunch of
all the information across the league so
the the standard URLs the URLs pretty
similar so you can go on the first page
and get a list of the league's and from
there you can figure out the the IDs for
the leagues and keep traversing
downwards so leagues will have teams
teams lot of players and then you go on
the player pages okay yeah excuse me I'm
curious if you have any advice or
anything that you've learned building
more generic scrapers as opposed to like
building a scraper for like one site to
pull off structured data that's one
thing building a scraper that's going to
go across multiple sites even if it's
just doing like article extraction or
like content extraction from pages do
you have any like tools or libraries
that you've had experience with that are
particularly good at that kind of
generic approach I would suggest some
more like scrapy which is a I've used
myself I know it's a tool that makes it
easier for a wide array of websites to
trade from so it's not within my my
scope of experience
so it sounds like you're recommending
phantom Jas over chromium is that just
kind of the way you presented that slide
have you used both and do you have any
reasons to use one over the other I
probably missed edit so I've been using
phantom Jas since I've been doing this
then jess is going to be shutting down I
believe it has so there's gonna be
transitioning toward chromium I'm still
using it just legacy because it's just
within my code I don't have too much
experience with loading chromium but as
it gets more mature something I would
suggested using over advantage a s
[Music]
yeah so a problem with the dynamic sites
what's about navigating in the sites is
there also possibility to do this with
phantom Jas or other tools to use but
they require the combination of domain
knowledge so you have an idea how
websites structured but using Heather's
browsing you can still load up the
content and navigate in a similar
fashion do you have any recommendations
for scraping on single page apps where
the URL might not change as the page
view changes and it just becomes more
difficult to navigate your crawler it's
kind of a similar answer is again
regards domain knowledge so it's
scraping very context-specific you have
to know what you're going for so a lot
of these I would imagine would be
similar in terms of the techniques to
solidify your spirit but you still
require knowing cycled into the function
of actually parsing the page of knowing
what what's on the page how it's how
it's written how it's built
[Music]
so you mentioned about using proxies and
I was wondering the proxies might shield
you from detection in terms of you know
the identity of the source of the
scraping attempt but Bezique does it
also shield you from you well there are
there are web servers that are clever
enough to map IP addresses to specific
geographical locations there's a proxy
you know protects you against that so if
I have a web server that tells me well
even though these are different IP
addresses from which this requests are
coming but they're all coming from the
same location
you know geolocation so that could to me
indicate that you know this is a clever
attempt disguised as multiple from
multiple sources how does it work in an
environment that yeah I thought when I
thought of I can see we're coming from
solution I think of there is so for
example in case I use digital ocean when
you created a VPS you can specify where
it's coming from so you can specify
which data center so you could create so
you get either if you want them all in
the same region or you could diversify
them so depending again on the context
of what you're trying to handle so I
would say create your VPS is based on
geographical locations that depend on
the context of what you're looking at
so so this is cool do you have a success
story
I mean who's the player that you found
from scraping that none of the other
teams could find I mean I can't speak
too much on that but when so we're a
little bit off topic so we're not data
like our decisions aren't based purely
on the data it's a combination of both
the qualitative and quantitative
analysis within the within the players
and we find the players that are best
our players that we all agree on we just
had the draft two weeks ago and in the
sixth round we got a player named Alexi
you that a ret though he plays in the
plays in Finland and he's bit of an
older player he's a player that we
identified a couple years ago and player
they hadn't really watched but we kept
pushing it to watch the sky so they
watching this year they liked them and
we end up dropped down so I mean that's
probably a good example where we our
work came in to look at the breadth of
players to try and pinpoint players we
think require further analysis and the
traditional scouts came and did further
analysis on their end and combined
really gap this is their back
you
alright there are no other questions
let's all give Joshua a round of
applause for the great talk
[Applause]